[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar cap guidelines for laboratory
detection and initial diagnosis of
monoclonal gammopathies i am kayleigh
bach of labyrinths and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by bindingsite to learn more please
visit us.bindingsite.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
david karen professor of pathology
university of michigan michigan medicine
dr karen you may now begin your
presentation
thank you
i'm david karen i'd like to thank
labrutz and the binding site for giving
me the opportunity to present the new
cap guidelines for the laboratory
detection and initial diagnosis of
monoclonal gammopathies
so these are my disclosures i do
work a bit with the binding site and
with uh sabia
so i have a question for all of you i'd
like you to do some work who is this man
and why is he not smiling is almost a
frown on his face
remember you know who he is he's
important for today's talk
it's henry bentz jones
and he's concerned he's concerned
because even today people misspell his
name so my next question for you does
henry benz jones use a hyphen in his
name or does he not you can find it both
ways in 2021 papers
so make your decision
and i will show you his
actual paper
henry benz jones wrote this in
1848
48
was published and uh he uh did not use a
hyphen in his name
and he created the very first tumor
marker the benz jones protein monoclonal
free light chains and we're going to be
talking about them a lot today so we owe
a lot to dr bens jones
if you're still wondering about the
hyphen some of you may be you can read
this
interesting article by dr rosenfeld in
which he
validates that henry benz jones never
used a hyphen in his name the reference
books when he was
during his lifetime always
published him under jones as do current
books
the hyphen was added by his descendants
presumably members of the bentz clan
and it was also misused by sir william
osler in a important textbook that he
wrote and i think dr osler was confusing
him vince jones with a dr baines jones
who did hyphen his name and he was a
prominent nephrologist in london at that
time
so today i hope that you are going to be
able to explain why we
needed to
produce these guidelines
and i hope that these will allow you to
standardize m-protein detection in your
laboratories and also to use these
features
the ratio of free light chains the
m-protein isotype and their
concentration to identify our patients
who are at the highest risks
so monoclonal gammopathies are a very
complex group of diseases and i like
jerry katzman's uh
discussion of them and he categorized
them into three groups the neoplastic
groups that we're going to be treating
due to their
plasma cell proliferation that would be
multiple myelomas the big guy there and
walden storms also but other cases other
conditions
then there's the
low tumor burden diseases
where the problem is the protein that
deposits and that would be in things
like al amyloid or neuropathy syndromes
and finally the premalignant conditions
which are very common such as monoclonal
gammopathy of undetermined significance
mgus or smoldering multiple myeloma
so what tools do we have in the
laboratory to pick these things up well
electrophoresis is a big one
gel based techniques have been
around for well over a hundred years now
and we use immunofixation to
characterize the m proteins that we
detect capillary electrophoresis is a
bit newer and it uses immunosubtraction
and we're going to be discussing that a
bit today
but there's a new kid on the block mass
spectrometry and we will spend some time
on that to help characterize the m
protein not for the initial detection
and then we use nephelometry or can use
turbidimetry to measure total a m kappa
n lambda
there's also a role for heavy light in
many things although not so much in the
initial detection and then there's the
serum free light chain test that we're
going to spend a good deal of time on
today
so why did we do this why are there new
guidelines for cap
it was it resulted from this survey that
john gensen reported in 2018 of 774 labs
in 38 countries
at that time two-thirds of the labs were
using gel electrophoresis and one-third
we're using capillary i think capillary
is a bit up by now
but
what were we concerned about it was the
result of what the physicians were using
to detect patients with monochromal
gammopathies the plurality the the
largest number came out to be
laboratories that did serum protein
electrophoresis only and they would only
reflex if they saw something on it
the next largest thing was the group was
these labs that used serum protein
electrophoresis only without automatic
reflexing and then there was the group
that used serum protein electrophoresis
and immunofixation and that's all they
did
those sound
good but in fact they're not
comprehensive enough why is that
well the minority of labs were using
techniques that did
detect monoclonal free light chains in
some way either through the serum free
light chain test or through urine but
sadly
that only represented
uh 30 of the labs more than 70 percent
of them did not detect free light chains
or
by the symmetry light chain test or
right by urine immuno fixation and
that's a problem
because as this classic study from dr uh
bob kyle at the mayo clinic shows of the
in
over a thousand cases of newly diagnosed
multiple myeloma
only
free light
kappa and lambda chains occurred in 20
so that's all that was being produced
and these cases might well have been
missed by those laboratories
why is it important that we get early
detection it's because we have new
therapies that work quite well today
whereas in the last part of the 20th
century the immediate survival was about
three to five years on therapies
by 2012 is from this study by mccarthy
in the new england journal of medicine
shows the survival was almost twice that
and it's even expanding faster now why
was that because of new therapies stem
cell transplants
immunomodulatory agents
the use of proteasome inhibitors like in
them
and even since 20
2015 the fda has approved the use of
therapeutic monoclonal antibodies that
have extended this even further we have
several patients in our
group here at michigan that are
surviving up to 20 years or more right
now
so the cap decided to put together a an
expert panel
to uh to look into this and they
included in this panel representatives
from the international myeloma working
group the american association of
clinical chemistry the american society
for hematology as well as the american
society for clinical pathology and the
questions that we are asking in at this
time were one what specimens are useful
in detecting monoclonal proteins what
are the appropriate tests to use
and what are the appropriate tests to
measure the monoclonal proteins and
we'll get into all these today
well if you receive archives of
pathology you've already seen this
article it came out a few months ago
if you haven't you can use this link to
the doi site online and you can get this
this for free
and it contains everything and many more
details than i'll be able to discuss in
this presentation
so let me go through the statements the
first one
order both serum protein electrophoresis
and serum free light chains for the
initial detection of monoclonal proteins
in all patients with suspected
monoclonal gammopathies the strength of
this is uh moderate that talks about the
level of evidence that we have
from the feedback the vast majority of
individuals agreed with it there were a
few individuals that said well we'd like
to include the serum immuno fixation
automatically but what we have
but i'll show you why we don't routinely
recommend doing that and some people
prefer using urine immuno fixation to
free light chain and uranium fixation is
a great test but i'll tell you why we
didn't recommend that
some of our data comes from this classic
study by dr katzman at the mayo clinic
of almost 2 000 patients with monoclonal
gammopathies we like this study because
it uh it shows in the columns it shows
the different tests that were done spe
serum protein electrophoresis ife serum
immunofixation uife is urine
immunofixation and flc is the free light
chain ratio and you see that in the
different columns
we are just using
some of those
markers to see which ones are going to
be detecting the numbers that you see in
the columns are the percent of detection
so let's start out with what we're
really doing
we're recommending serum
protein electrophoresis and the serum
free light chain test how good did it do
in picking up multiple myeloma and
waldenstrom microglobulin anemia it
picked up 100 percent of the cases that
was also picked up when you added urine
immuno fixation and serum immune to
fixation
or both both both of those what about
al amyloid well there the the
use of all four picked up 98.1 percent
and the protein electrophoresis with
free light chains picked up 96.2 which
is actually a little better than if you
just use the urine and the serum
immunofixation but we'll talk in more
detail about amyloid later
what about other conditions
mgus monoclonal gammopathy of
undetermined significance with a large
category
it's very common but we missed almost 12
percent of them is that a problem
it is not the first place
monoclonal gammopathy of undetermined
significance is not a treatable disease
there is no recommendation to screen for
it
there is a study going on in iceland
right now that is trying to decide if it
would be worth screening
the average individual with mgus
progresses to multiple myeloma at the
rate of only one percent per year
and the cases that we missed would be
cases of very low risk in amgus why is
that
because high risk mgos have abnormal
free light chains and to be missed by us
you would by definition have a normal
ratio of free light chains
also high risk mgus have a relatively
large amount of monoclonal gammopathy
greater than 1.5 grams per deciliter and
we would certainly have seen these by
the serum protein electrophoresis so
you're we're missing low risk people
but there is one other area that's
important neuropathies
palms syndrome polyneuropathies they are
picked up best by the in serum
immunofixation alone as shown here
and so we
we do recommend that patients who are
being worked up for neuropathies that
are associated with monoclonal
gammopathies to have the additional test
of immunofixation that is a minority
minority of them as you can see by the
numbers in this table
immunoglobulin structure is important in
considering the things we're talking
about
i show here a intact immunoglobulin
molecule and the letters a b c d e and f
are antigenic determinants the things
that we can react antibodies
create antibodies to to detect
immunoglobulins but e and f are hidden
in the interior of the molecule
on the right is the serum free light
chain and you see that
here
we have e and f are now available
those are the epitopes those are the
antigens that
bradwell and colleagues used for the
initial study that developed the serum
free light chain test
this is data from dr bradwell's initial
report that show you several things
about the serum free light chain tests
to test on a large number of individuals
with the antibodies he created
on the
left you have the lambda
free light chains expressed in logs on
the
x-axis you have the kappa like chains
expressed in logs
the group of violet colored samples
toward the middle are normal serum
patients that had kappa light chain
multiple myeloma are the black dots that
are all in the
bottom right
quadrant the patients that have lambda
like chain multiple myeloma are the blue
triangles that are in the upper right we
also detected many cases of al amyloid
with this technique although not all of
them and patients with renal disease do
tend to have higher numbers because the
light chains don't readily pass into the
urine
this was an important discovery but it
took but it wasn't until the next year
when dr
katzman at the mayo clinic
did a study to create a reference
interval and a diagnostic range it's
important to explain this because this
has a key is a key feature for detection
of the monoclonal gammopathies with our
guideline
so first he used
282 normal individuals uh who did not
have monochroma gammopathies to create a
reference a 95 reference interval we
typically do that in clinical
laboratories and here shown the
the range for kappa lambda and the free
light chain ratio at the two standard
deviations
now dr
katzman's test was done on a bade
excuse me dade pairing bn2 instrument
and it's important that you know what
instrument it's performed on because
that's where these guidelines came from
now the two
the 95 reference interval is readily
understandable that's plus or minus two
standard deviations and we use it in the
laboratory often
but he created something unique a
diagnostic range over there it says 0.26
to 1.65
how did he get that why is that
important
well let's take a look at dr katzman's
data here it is this is all this is his
study on the left you have the
diagnostic interval on the
on the x-axis we have the age of the
patients some of the circles are clear
and others are
filled in and that's just from two
different groups of individuals the ones
that were filled in were from frozen
samples which were determined to be uh
not harmed they're still useful in this
case so let's take a look at what two
standard deviations would be there it is
and you see we do have about
two and a half percent high two and a
half percent low as expected dr katzman
didn't think that it was a good idea to
call people positive
when they are normal individuals they
they do not have uh
evidence for a monochromal gammopathy
because monoclonal gammopathy is a pre
neoplastic condition mgus is not
neoplastic but it's considered
pre-neoplastic
and so he decided to exclude all these
how did he do that
he picked the highest one
he picked the lowest one
and created this range
that's where these numbers come from and
it's important that you know that
it's hard to reproduce that because you
don't have these same people all the
time at this same time
and laboratory reagents especially
polyclonal antibodies can change with
time so it must be regulated quite
carefully
there are many reports in the literature
there are several publications that
report measurements of free light chains
vary with
the
instrument that is being used to do for
their detection
um
so i took when when looking at the
literature this is the initial catzman
study on the top showing the 0.26 to
1.65 diagnostic range which is what most
labs use today
but they the um
the manufacturer
also notes quite clearly that each
laboratory should verify the
transferability of the expected values
to their own population
and if necessary determine their own
reference interval
the method that's being used makes a
difference so here we have catspins on
the top let's go look at the cotton
study you see there are five entries for
cotton in 2018.
they had a large number a large amount
of sample from many
normal individuals and they send them to
three different places dartmouth
hitchcock laboratories the ohio state
university and the university of north
carolina
and what you see here is very different
diagnostic ratios found for all of these
when you look at the image
which is the top one
it was fairly similar to the diagnostic
range
that katzman came up with 20 years
before
slightly lower but the upper end of it
was much tighter at 1.26
same exact samples using the same method
but on a different instrument the kobus
showed that the bottom number is quite
higher
virtually twice as high as the original
meaning that it would pick up the sum if
you if you were using the original
catchment numbers you might
it would pick up some of the
cases of lambda that were between 0.26
and 0.50 and the top was also much
higher 2.43 versus 1.65 indicating that
there would be fewer false positives
with this method
then you get to the spa plus
system
and that showed a kind of in-between
number of 0.36
for the lower end and 2.07 for the high
n
and then you have the optilites this i
think is very important and it gives me
hope because you can see there's quite a
variety of things
here the optilite was actually the exact
same test was being done on the exact
same instrument in two different
institutions ohio state university and
the university of north carolina and
you'll see the the happy news is it
performs exactly the same well there's a
slight difference but
this is virtually the same so the it is
the instrument that is the difference
not the location
not the the uh the assay itself it is
the instrument that makes the difference
and it's important because the optolight
is as i will show you a critically
important info instrument right now at
least in the united states
this is from the cotton data so you can
see what happened this is the
kappa to lambda ratios it's color coded
the red square shows the original
katzman boundaries and you'll see many
of the cases fall out of that with the
new testing and with the image which is
a very tight one
at the other end many cases would be
missed with that range
the most recent data comes from morales
garcia and in madrid
where they once again developed a
higher range even than the the other
opulite this was done three years later
and so the numbers are different and
just shows that maybe with different
batches you also need to make changes
although again it's in a different
country maybe
there's more
different
different
variation in terms of the the capillary
ratios in those individuals
but here is from their study i'm
graphing it the same as this is from
their work just like cats here's what
they had for a two standard deviation
range again some high some low this is
katzman they picked a high one a low one
and that's where they came out with
their ratio
here how common is this technique this
shows us the
current from the 2021
cap survey
on this on the on the free light chain
essay showing you the binding site
reagents siemens reagents and diazyme
reagents that are used that were used in
that study
this shows which laboratories were using
the image the optilite the spa
cobus and the siemens nephelometer
overwhelmingly laboratories are using
the binding site technique
and
the the largest number use the uh
optilite so once again it is important
for laboratories to make their checks to
see what that diagnostic interval the
the the test itself works fine as you
saw in the ohio state and unc data they
were virtually identical
some people do still prefer using the
urine test you're an immuno fixation
it's not a bad test it's a there's good
things about it the problem is you need
a different specimen you need different
reagents and the clinicians just don't
tend to send it even when you request it
um this shows a
urine protein electrophoresis that has
an overflow pattern the nice thing about
the urine is you can do an immune
fixation on that and then you can
take a 24 hour sample and actually
measure the m protein so it's a very
useful test very sensitive and when you
have a positive free light chain
reaction you do need to do immuno
fixation on the serum and the urine to
confirm it
here's a study from mctaggart showing
one of the reasons that we didn't use a
urine immunofixation as the initial
screening is the recommendation they
were looking at patients suspected of
having plasma cell dysgrazia and out of
these almost 3 000 patients 124 4.4
percent did have plasma disorders 17
percent were malignant that was a little
less than one percent of the study
population and they had
paired urine samples in only one out of
five twenty percent
and the problem with that is as shown in
the circles is that they missed one case
of a treatable disease light chain
deposition disease and they missed six
cases of mgus but unfortunately these
are mgus patients who did have abnormal
free light chains and were at higher
risk for progression
serum abnormal serum free light chains
can mean a lot of things you can see it
in chronic kidney disease just because
they have more trouble getting through
the glomeruli
more ease getting through the gland
chronic inflammation
is another what thing that in some cases
will increase the serum free light
chains however in many of the studies
including dr bradwell's original one the
the chronic inflammation doesn't that
often cause an increase in the ratio
part of that could have something to do
with different instruments used in
laboratories
there is normal population variation
always and of course there can be lots a
lot variations in reagents
statement two for us is that
laboratorians should confirm serum
protein electrophoresis abnormality
that's suspicious for the presence of an
m protein by doing another test usually
that's immunofixation or alternative
that's it is okay there are there's two
other ones that are very good
immunosubtractions and the new kid on
the block mass fix and we're going to go
over these
the thing the strength of this guideline
is moderate
and most people agreed with this
so what are these suspicious bands where
are they people tend to just look in the
gamma region or maybe the beta gamma
region but you can find monoclonal
immunoglobulins
anywhere from the alpha right through
the gamma region
they are often obscured by things of the
things that live there such as
haptoglobin altitude macro robulin
transferrin in the beta 1 region c3 and
c3 breakdown products can be suspicious
in the beta gamma region there's
fibrinogen i know you're not supposed to
have fibrinogen in
in plasma in serum specimens but some
people are on anticoagulants sometimes
samples get drawn in the wrong tube
so you have to do a procedure to to
detect these other things that can cause
problems on capillary electrophoresis
are contrast radio contrast dyes
and some drugs that will give you uh
spikes for all these things you need to
follow up with immunosubtraction
immunofixation or mass fix
so immunofixation is a
process that's familiar probably to most
of you and that you just re-perform the
electrophoresis and where you see a band
you check it by looking by reacting the
serum with gam kappa and lambda
antibodies and as shown here in number
four of this figure uh it is this this
particular case is an igm kappa
monoclonal protein
sometimes they can be trickier though in
this in case number eight here you see a
strong g
lambda but there's also a weak band in
the kappa region
is that a
g kappa that is is hiding underneath the
g peak or could it be free kappa or
could it be a d
kappa what about the rare e kappa so you
do need to do some more work
here's a case that shows a small
cathodeal band very tiny i'm not sure
that everybody would agree it's a band
but it's there and i want to show you
how
defective immunosubtraction is uh
uh as a as a as a relatively new
technique it's been around for about 20
years but only about the last 10 are
people really using it
effectively
so here's that case and i want to show
you how to
look at immunosubtractions you can see
the band there in the elp lane but after
you see it there i think when i see a
band there i like to look down at
at the
at the
bottom two lanes the kappa and the
lambda to see which one subtracted so
when immunosubtraction you are removing
things so it's labeled igg you remove
the g
a you remove the a m they removed the m
and kappa and lambda likewise if you
look at the bottom with the kappa there
is still a little round lump left after
you have done the subtraction whereas
that lump is not present in the lambda
let's take a look at it here because
this shows us that it is a
because the lambda removes it
that would be called an igg
lambda monoclonal gammopathy it's very
small but it's there
immunosubtraction is just as sensitive
as immunofixation
ah a little the blue arrow shows you
that there is uh
the restriction is actually more
prominent when you remove the
non-involved isotype so you've removed
the kappa in this case which made the
little restriction look even more
obvious getting rid of background is
always a good thing to do
and why care about such small bands you
ask because
they need to be followed
they may increase very quickly
mass fix is the new kid on the block
dr murray at mayo clinic let me come up
there and spend some time with him about
a year ago and
[Music]
look at his procedure of mass fix which
is now their routine instead of
immunofixation
just as with immunosubtraction you have
to pre-treat the serum uh to to
to use this technique
with the of subtraction it just
subtracted out the particular band
it's the it works the other way with
immunofixation they purify the igg am
kappa and lambda fractions from serum
using beads coated with specific
antibodies then they reduce those
fractions they break the disulfide bonds
and that creates light and heavy chain
versions of all these molecules
that's done because smaller molecules
are more easy to use in the
mass spectrometer
they in their laboratory they're using a
maldi tof method maldi stands for matrix
assisted laser desorption ionization so
they blast they they blast these uh
molecules with a laser beam uh in a
matrix and that ionizes them and it
launches them into the mass spectrometer
and the
instrument they were using was the same
when we used it michigan for studying
microbiology specimens and i bet many of
you have these in your laboratory
they then get five patterns just like we
get five patterns with immunosubtraction
gam kappa lambda and we get five immuno
subtraction patterns with the in with
the immo subtraction
dr murray prefers to overlay the
patterns um
uh
in
in this pattern
so here we're only seeing three things
you're looking at the light chains that
were attached to igg here
or the light chains attached to iga and
the iga band
or the light chains that are attached to
the igm in the igm band so the dark
line
here in the igg
are the like chains that were associated
with normal igg two small
two very smooth humps
what you're seeing here this is the
the on the x-axis is the um mass to
charge ratio you see the number 11 and
12 below that stands for e 11 000
and
twelve thousand it says lc plus two that
means that those like chains had a
charge of plus two so the mass charge
ratio is a half of what it would be
the eleven then would indicate a
molecular weight of 22 000 the 12 would
be 24 000. so you're looking at precise
molecular weights of these molecules
for iga
here's the band the black band shows you
what the iga is nice smooth bands
showing two humps
igm the same thing the black band there
shows you their
three little humps they're small but
very smooth
the blue
nice blue
peak is normal
free lambda so in immunofixation you
have your lambda band that would be the
lambda and
the for the orange band
that is the kappa and they have the same
kappa band and the same lambda band in
all three so you can compare
each heavy ch
the heavy chains
the light chains from the heavy chains
to the light chain types
how does that work in a real
case here's a monoclonal gammopathy
if you look at the
black bands here
this is for the g
the m and the a rather and the m so on
the bottom let's look at the m band it's
very there's there's not much of it
that's because this is a myeloma patient
with immunoparesis it's suppressed
the iga band is also very low it's
suppressed
but in the igg there is a good deal of
it and if we blow that image up a little
bit you can see that there is a
definite spike it is the patient's igg
kappa
and uh
um a smaller band labeled elo that's
elotuzumab you can identify elotuzumab
and daratumumab also if
it has if it was present and there's al
always a
matrix effect because the
the monochrome protein is embedded in a
matrix when the laser hits it until you
get a second peak that relates to that
so this is a pretty nice example of how
you could diagnose an igg kappa
monoclonal protein
it is not only more precise than
immunofixation it is much more sensitive
as shown here this is an igm kappa
monoclonal protein that you can see on
the
top immunofixation that's labeled four
and it's pretty easy to see on that fix
to its left is the uh
mass mass fixed pattern uh clearly
showing a band
uh when you dilute it one to a hundred
the band
almost disappears from the immuno
fixation easily is there with the mass
fix and it's totally gone by the one to
two hundred uh dilution and it's still
obvious in the mass fix
statement three
laboratories or clinical care providers
should provide should follow up on serum
free light and abnormal serum free light
chain
ratio for the presence of a
monoclonal immunoglobulin protein by
doing a serum immuno fixation or
alternative method with similar
sensitivity i sub or mass fix
the strength of this guideline is low
but it is important
let's take a look
uh the serum free light chain uh will be
able to find mixed
missed monoclonal proteins as shown by
dr angela dispenzieri also from the mayo
clinic in this lancet article
and what she did was she
performed serum free light chain testing
on over 18 000
individuals had who had previously been
studied by dr kyle in in another work
and uh that study just used serum
protein electrophoresis and would reflex
the immunofixation if they found
something
in this study
on those same samples
dr dispenzieri found 610 cases that were
positive for an abnormal free light
chain which is 3.3 percent of those
cases
213 of those individuals already had
immunoglobulin heavy chain expression
mgus
but using immunofixation on all 610 they
found 57 cases that had intact m
proteins that had been missed that is
they were hidden in the serum protein
electrophoresis pattern but not obvious
here's a case for you to look at for a
second what do you think this is
i
i've said that it looks like an acute
phase pattern to me the albumen is low
it says l thereby the albumin level it
says the alpha 1 is high and alpha 2 is
high
the c3 band which is the first band in
the beta region looks a little low
compared to the
i'm sorry the transform band is a little
low the beta 1 band compared to the c3
band which is the beta 2 band
it's not just acute phase there's
something else going on here it has an
abnormal free light chain ratio and um
that caused us to do an immunofixation
on it and the immunofixation shows us a
band in the iga and in the kappa it's an
iga kappa monochrome protein that would
have been missed had we not done our
serum free light chain tests as dr
dispenzieri recommends
so this is an important article by
thorne and colleagues that that
corrected a
misstatement that i make in my uh uh
2012 book i said that you can't see
something that you
it can't uh
you can't subtract something that you
can't see but in fact you can see subtle
things so immunosubtraction is really
equivalent to immunofixation and dr
thorne's very careful article recent
article does a great job of showing this
and she shows something even more
important that we need training in the
new techniques that's not a big surprise
but she's the first to really show this
well what she did was she had a group of
in in individuals who were reviewers who
had seen immunosubtraction
and they they were tested on a bunch of
samples and then they trained these
individuals and then they saw different
samples not the same ones and their
sensitivity improved by 19
so a lot of the earlier papers that said
that immuno
subtraction wasn't as sensitive as
immunofixation probably is looking at an
issue of appropriate training
in in her study she had a large number
of patients when an m spike was present
in the patient's serum by protein
electrophoresis the immunofixation and
immunosubtraction both found 615 cases
there was one case that was present with
immunofixation and that
immunosubtraction missed but actually
immunosubtraction did better because
they found 12 cases that immunofixation
had missed
when there was no monoclonal
immunoglobulin protein spike seen on the
routine protein electrophoresis things
get very dicey
only 157 of these 496 cases were
positive for both immunoficks and
immunosubtraction
the uh immunofix was able to pick up 167
that immunosubtraction didn't and the
immune subtraction picked up a little
more 172 that immunofixation didn't
clearly these are
interesting techniques they each have
their advantages and disadvantages we
use both in our laboratory at the
university of michigan and i thank dr
thorn for the her efforts in in
promoting this technique and showing
some great examples you should read this
paper
so here's something for you to interpret
it's a
more subtle case
so let's see how your skills are in this
so in this particular instance we have
if you compare the kappa and the lambda
areas there's something subtracting on
the anodal side of kappa that is not
subtracting in the lambda
and another side
which heavy chain also does this and if
we look around at it
it's the iga
so this is an iga kappa i know this
looks subtle but it's kind of like a lot
of other things that we do in pathology
recognizing the first time you see
subtle things oh nobody can see this but
but after you've seen
two three four of these it just jumps
right out at you
statement four
critical care providers should order all
of them serum protein electrophoresis
serum free light chain serum
immunofixation and urine immunofixation
when the patients are suspected of
having al amyloid systemic amyloid
symptoms
the evidence for this is uh moderate
and most uh respondents agreed that this
was the right thing to do this is the
original
katzman study i showed you earlier they
had a huge number of cases of mayo as a
referral center of course
for al amyloid and you'll notice here
that they have uh by
and we detect by the serum
protein electrophoresis and free ly
chain 96.2 percent of the cases a little
better than if we just did the
immunofixation and the urine
immunofixation
but you can get a few more uh two two or
three more percent when you do when you
add the urine immunofixation and serum
in a fixation and we think this should
be done
and this is a study from palladini
showing you at least one example of why
he has all kinds of examples in this
paper which you i encourage you to look
at but this i picked this one out
because it's six patients who had a
biclonal gammopathy so we had over on
the right
we i'm circling that two of these three
free light chain cap lambda ratios were
absolutely normal
if you look in the middle column the
urine immune fixation those two samples
were positive by the urine
immunofixation
so doing all of these makes sense in
those
for those uncommon cases of
al amyloid suspicion
so what's going on here
here is a serum that looks pretty normal
to me normally you as well
i don't see anything abnormal about it
the g and m look normal up there it is
the free like chain for lambda is high
and the ratio is low
so let's if it's a free lambda i would
think well maybe it would be in the
urine
but it's not in the urine of this
patient there's not a whole lot in the
urine of this patient so we're
not having any help finding it
this is a patient that has al amyloid
and the lambda is how we
detected and followed this patient
biopsy proven
so what this shows you is the the
i the free lambda levels in green and
the free capital levels in blue and
their ratio in violet over a period of
seven years going from 2013 to 2020 in
the case the sample i just showed you
was somewhere in the middle here 2018
and it shows how we were using the
lambda light chain to follow this
patient's treatment
statement five clinical care providers
should not order the heavy light chain
isotype assay for the initial detection
of m proteins in patients with suspected
monocalls it's a fine assay but it is
not meant for this the strength of it to
support this is low
the
example i'm showing is from dr katzman's
study uh where he used a three range uh
to um uh
not inc not include normal individuals
in in in this
similar to what he did with the serum
free light chain test
and he found that looking at
diagnostic serum samples
there were 32 patients that had a
monoclonal iggm protein 31 were detected
by the protein electrophoresis alone 30
were detected by the abnormal heavy
light chain ratio
that ratio did a bit better in the
post-treatment sample follow-ups but
pretty similar overall it didn't make a
difference and so we think wow this is
useful for many things it is not
it was not recommended for the initial
detection
statement six
clinical care providers should not use
the total
intact light chain test
for quantification of m proteins in
patients suspected of having multiple
myeloma
so there's two light chain tests
available there's a one that measures
light chains that are attached to
immunoglobulins that they're part of an
intact immunoglobulin molecule as well
as the free light chain and ones that
measure only the free light chain
people confuse these and that's why we
think you should not be using this test
really at all
this shows the difference in the these
two if you look at the
uh the
different light chains here the mean
ratio for the uh free light chain test
is about one zero point nine six whereas
total light chains is two
is about is quite different two
the other thing i'm showing you here is
that they're different in three orders
of magnitude of course there are a lot
more intact immunoglobulin molecules in
the serum because they're too big to get
out of the urine quickly that's why the
light chains do not
stay in the serum
we did used to use this this is an
article that i published 34 years ago
that i'm telling you not to do anymore
jeff warren john lowell and i put
together this where we could diagnose
monochrome gammopathies using high
resolution electrophoresis and the total
light chain test don't do it anymore
please it's my own article i'm
i'm mixing it
okay statement seven in patients with
intact monoclonal proteins that are
outside of the gamma region by serum
protein electrophoresis it's often uh
difficult to measure them
a's and m
happen
more often but sometimes they're g's and
we we're recommending quantitation using
using the total immunoglobulin of that
isotype measured by nephelometry a g or
m
we're still saying that quan if if you
can if you if you can distinguish the m
protein from the background by with
something like immunosubtraction you may
try to you may you may be able to
measure that but we we the problem with
that we is that it doesn't give much
harmonization between different
laboratories i will show you an example
the strength of evidence for this is
very low
booze from a study a report from the
international myeloma working group in
2014 where they did recommend that for a
beta-migrating monoclonal protein
initially you could just measure the
total iga
they didn't measure gnm because the m
protein concentration with g and m's
often is overestimated by nephelometry
nonetheless it could give you harmony i
will show you an example here's a
patient with a spike in the beta region
and a little spike in the anodal end of
the gamma region
g is
495 a is 1900 m is 26. if you do even a
subtraction and now you've seen a few
cases you can see with the iga
it subtracts out and the little bit
subtracts out in the gamma region as
well so it's an iga
kappa
iga kappa monoclonal protein
you could do a immuno
a perpendicular drop on this to get a
measurement in this case i got one
measurement of 1.84 for the bigger peak
and 0.08 for the smaller one adding them
up i got 1.92 so it looks not
unreasonable if you look back to the
other one
it pretty much covers the area that had
been cleared it was that's not an
unreasonable thing to do
but we're telling you probably the
better thing to do is just do the total
iga which gave you virtually the same
answer 1900 milligrams per deciliter is
the same as 1.219
1.92 grams per deciliter
and the advantage of this is that these
are the measurements i made that doesn't
make them perfect by any means and
if somebody else in my lab might measure
it slightly differently in a different
lab they might get totally different
numbers
but the iga the nephelometry number
everybody would get the same
it harmonizes what we do
statement eight
laboratories should report both
quantitative levels of free light and
free lambda as well as the
the ratio of the free light chain and
this
the evidence for this is very low
because it's also fairly straightforward
so there's not a lot of other studies on
this
um
it is basically what we're showing you
with from bradwell's classic study to
the more recent studies it is the ratio
that is important so just reporting the
free
light chains
without the ratio is not appropriate
statement 9 shows that providers can use
several features to to
to help
distinguish
progression those those patients who are
at high risk for progression to multiple
myeloma or b cell lympho proliferative
disorders so they can use the ratio that
we've been talking about of the free
light chain
they can use the isotype now igm isotype
is the one that is at the most increased
risk for progression
they can use the
measurement of the m protein if it's 1.5
grams per deciliter or greater they're
at a higher risk of progressing
they can use the
immunoparesis decrease in non-involved
isotypes below reference intervals and i
will show you the examples here
the strength for this evidence is low
here we see a study from dr kyle in 2018
where he shows that
the igg
is the least to progress
as shown in the bars on the right
um the m-protein level if you're less
than 1.5 grams per deciliter your
chances of progressing are about half
that of
the individuals that have a uh higher
amount of
immunoglobulin monoclonal protein and
the free light chain ratio once again is
a very important
feature to to
look at to see if they're progressing
it's even a bit stronger than the m
protein level
this is looking at immunoparesis the
the immunosuppressions that the patients
have this is a recent study from gang on
287 newly diagnosed multiple myeloma
patients and they're comparing
progression on people that have
deep or partial immunoparesis that's the
red band versus the controls and you can
see if you look at the 50 probability of
progression there is uh
almost a two two year difference
good practice issue is that is the use
of measurement in
monochrome gammopodies as we've been
showing you it's very important in
looking at risk of progressions or ones
that are greater than 1.5 grams per
deciliter
it's important to have the initial
measurements so that you can follow
patients with mgus how can you tell if
it's going up or down if you don't know
what the original m protein is
it's important for establishing the
diagnosis of smoldering multiple myeloma
which is a much is a higher
level of risk
than
mgus and that requires a even if their
bone marrow plasma cells are normal if
they have greater than 3 grams per
deciliter they are considered a
smoldering multiple myeloma
and once again it's important to follow
smoldering multiple myeloma with that
and for treating multiple myeloma
patients to see what their responses to
therapy need to know what the original m
protein was before the treatment
but there are two ways to measure
the monoclonal proteins you can do a
perpendicular drops as i'm showing on
the left or tangent skimming showing you
on the right
so we're using the exact same
demarcation points i have the arrows at
the exact same point i didn't change
them when i switched from the one to the
other and you can see it's measured as
1.47 with a perpendicular drop and 0.95
on the right
the problem with the perpendicular drop
is that it includes a lot polychol
immunoglobulins beneath it so its
accuracy depends on what the ratio is
of the m spike to the polycon material
beneath it
the problem with tangent skimming is
that it doesn't benefit from
having the sample go all the way down to
the bottom and you do miss a bit of the
actual m protein
there's a study by christoph shield of
the two methods perpendicular drop and
tangent skimming published in 2008
shield
was using capillary electrophoresis at
the time
he used two different m proteins
monochrome proteins one 50 grams per
liter of the g and 25 grams per liter of
an a and he did serial dilutions on
these
then he looked at their recovery ideal
would be
a straight line going across from 100
the x-axis shows the
m-protein concentration after the
dilution 10 20 30 40 and 50 grams per
deciliter
and the recovery is on the y-axis and he
shows us that with perpendicular drop
the a and the g were linear down to
fifth around 15 grams per liter but
using tangent skimming he could detect
it
one log lower
i prefer tangent skimming for gamma
region and proteins but it gets dicey
when you get into the beta gamma and
beta region it's hard because there are
other proteins there that
interfere with it which is why the
guidelines say that for those proteins
one should consider using the total a g
or m
the um
perpendicular drop using the same
demarcations though when the m spike is
big such as in patients that are more
likely to have monoclonal multiple
myeloma
there's usually not very much difference
between the two
harmonization problem with current
measurements well each method works well
within a laboratory so if you're using
the
same laboratory all the time you're
going to get
good results from one one to the other
however between different methods
it does not compare well you cannot
compare
well use
a laboratory using tangent skimming to
one that's using perpendicular drop
following patients with the same methods
in the same laboratory is the best thing
to do it sounds impractical right now
one of the hopes for the future that i
have is from observing mass spectrometry
it improves precision of detecting the
monochrome spike and it should harmonize
things between laboratories because now
instead of just talking about a band
that's in the fast gamma region or the
slow
beta region you have a precise molecular
weight
and you can do quantifications with this
technique as well
so our in summary this is what we're
doing if you have a patient that has a
clinical suspicion of a monoclonal
gammopathy you're going to perform serum
protein electro freezes and serum free
light chain and there's an asterisk by
the light chain because if the patient
has symptoms of a neuropathy then you
need to add serum immunofixation
if they're being worked out worked up
for al amyloid you need to add both
serum and urine immunofixation
if those turn out to be
if either the protein electrophoresis or
the uh
serum free light chain are suspicious
you need to perform
immuno fixation immune subtraction or
mass fix
you also need to measure the gamma m
spike
and you also need to perform g a and m
measurements
for non-gamma-m spikes and also to
detect individuals who have
immunoparesis
so if you have
again if you receive archives of
pathology you've already seen the
article this is the article in detail it
will do a much better job i'm sure than
i have done today to show these to you
and
you can feel free to contact me if you
do have questions about this
finally
i'd like to
remind you that a happy vince jones
is a non-hyphenated
benz jones
so thank you very much for your
attention and i'll be glad to answer
your questions
thank you dr karen for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks we perform the tests
ordered by our physicians and probably
not all of these orders are in line with
these guidelines any advice on how to
inform the ordering physicians about the
guidelines and change their ordering
patterns
i think it's very important to work
directly and very personally with your
clinicians we we love to meet with ours
to attend different rounds that the
clinicians have to talk to the chiefs of
service
and show them the data they show them
the guidelines and the reasons why the
the idea is to have a not only improve
service in one place but to have a bit
of harmonization of how service is done
so that everybody reaches the high
quality that
and by choosing tests only serum protein
electrophoresis and the serum free light
chain test we're only doing two tests
so it should be relatively affordable we
were concerned about that too and
for different locations and um and the
other thing is that in
it is it may not be obvious to
clinicians that the subtle differences
in the tests and the things that the
tests are good or not quite as good at
so that is
what i would recommend just get together
with your clinicians work with them talk
to the chiefs of services
and walk down the hall and actually talk
to them in person with a mask on of
course these days
great thank you our next question asks
are there or
are these the first cap guidelines in
monoclonal gammopathies or are there
earlier versions if there are earlier
versions what are the differences
between the two
yes there was a version in 1999 um it
came out
and the differences relate to the fact
that the serum free light chain test was
not invented until 2001 by dr bradwell
that certainly created a huge difference
in 1999 many of the protein
electrophoresis techniques and did not
provide crisp separation of beta 1 from
beta 2
bands which is important in seeing
beta-migrating monoclonal
proteins or suspicious bands and today
techniques like capillary
electrophoresis by both of the
manufacturers very good they're the
gel electrophoresis
most just about all of them have much
better resolution and we also have
better studies we have much better
studies of looking at the the results
of these tests and finally
it's the treatments as i showed you in
the start of the talk the therapies
prior to
the year 2000 were very poor and it
didn't make a huge difference
when or how you were diagnosed but now
we have we have
the treatments that are milder more
focused and they're getting better and
better all the time so it is really very
important to pick this up as soon as you
can
thank you dr karen next question here
asks are cap guidelines mandatory and
enforceable
no these are guidelines um
these are these are not um
these are the suggestions from a group
of experts
we took people that represented
all the major in in
groups that write about this technique
so we had representatives we actually
had the person who was the lead author
uh dr sacha kumar
from uh the international myeloma
working group was work worked on our
board we had dr david murray who
has
does the mass fix technique we had
dr mcconnell we had all kinds of experts
from around the country we had
technologists that actually do the
assays so
these are our recommendations from
people who have studied this and worked
on this for years for decades it doesn't
mean everything's perfect it doesn't
mean we've got everything right we
certainly are interested in listening to
to questions and ideas
but
we hope that people will take these into
consideration and maybe someday this
will become part of
inspection guidelines but i think just
working for the patient this is a good a
good start
great thank you our next question here
asks what are the best practices to
adopt these guidelines in our lab do you
have any advice are these guidelines
followed in your laboratory
uh the best practices to follow these
guidelines is to just go over them with
your your your group and
and see what is practical
if it uh
you you don't need to adopt
immunosubtraction if you're not
currently doing it you certainly don't
need to adopt doing mass uh fix if you
don't have that ready
the the the mass fix is not broadly used
right now uh it's used i know at the
mayo clinic memorial sloan kettering
where dr thorin is and dr morada they do
it
we do not do that at the university of
michigan right now
we're aware of mass fix and we do send
cases to the mayo clinic to do mass fix
on some of our samples so that might be
an answer for some institutions who
don't have these available you can
always refer problem cases to them
that's not going to be it's not a lot of
our cases right now
people ask me well is something like
mass fix
is it
cost effective
dr murray tells me it is faster and
costs less to do the mass fix than what
it used to cost them to do
um
immunofixation at his laboratory
so we do some of them at the university
of michigan we don't do all of them at
the university of michigan but i think
it's it's like a lot of things
it was designed to be cost-effective
as well as focused on the best practices
available for patients
so look at it
work with your your technologists work
with your clinicians to see what works
best for you and gradually adopt them
wonderful thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question here so
we'll wrap up with this one and this ask
so these guidelines are about the
diagnosis of monoclonal gammopathies are
they applicable to follow-up or
monitoring of the patients
sure it's uh it's for the um it's it's
for patients who are
we you're testing patients who have a
suspicion of a monoclonal gammopathy and
that will vary so if you have a a
neurology patient that has
peripheral neuropathies
paresthesias and no other explanation
one explanation might be that
monochromal gammopathy and so that's why
when you order the m-protein study on
that patient you want to order the
immuno fixation because as i showed you
it's going to be a little more sensitive
than just doing the protein
electrophoresis and the and the serum
free light chain test alone
but once you have that diagnosis it's
very helpful in following them it's
essential how do you know if the mgus
patient is is is
progressing uh with their condition
some mgus's can be stable for decades
is going nowhere but we know that as a
group they progress one percent a year
to
multiple myeloma or another b-cell
lymphoproliferative disorder so you do
want to catch those things as early as
you can especially with our newer drugs
today so yes it is it's definitely more
than just the initial detection the
initial detection you want to
characterize it so you know what you're
looking for in the future and you want
to measure it so you can follow the
progression of the disease
wonderful well thank you again dr karen
for your time today and your important
research we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor binding site for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you